before we go we have to talk about  abba's triumphant return to the red  carpet yes the iconic swedish pop stars  attended the premiere of their new  digital concert voyage in london where  they returned to the stage as avatars of  themselves the group created the live  show with the help of georgia lucas's  special effects company or sfx as james  corden says and according to some of the  members their dance moves are even  better than they remembered bye-bye  i love to see myself yes  yeah it's very amazing the work they  have put into this project you know it's  unbelievable i can tell you  and uh i never knew i had such amazing  moves no  no  i thought that was quite good but that's  even  yes even better now  [Music]  [Applause]